[Music]  someone once told me  that the reality i thought i knew  was just one  of many  be careful which paths you travel down  stronger than you have lost their way  you think there will be no consequences  we're in the end game now  i sacrificed everything  and it meant  nothing  oh strange  what have you done  i never meant for this to happen  you cannot control everything  you brought this  on yourself  break the rules and become a hero  i do it and i become the enemy  this doesn't seem fair  dr strange to the multiverse of madness  you get pg-13 be the first to see the  mind-bending phenomena in premium large  format and imax tomorrow  [Music]  you